is it worse than social or is it worse
in person I think you both I think the
world that we live in right now and I
think because of covid and everything
can lock down and people just got more
enticed with social media and internet
everything like people don't know how to
talk to people people don't know how to
communicate people don't know how to
approach a person people don't even know
how to have a phone conversation just
text me everything's text voice note no
I let's have a conversation let's see if
we can actually speak for five minutes
and I'm still enticed in the
conversation yeah that'll be that'd be a
nice challenge exactly if social media
went away tomorrow how would that impact
dating
I think it would improve it after a
while yeah you've got so much choice now
yeah it's just there's always a nicer
new person around the corner so you
might as well keep swiping I've never
done online do you no and I never would
people would have to be more selective
wouldn't they'd have to be more more
intelligent more sophisticated about the
way that they men would have to be more
sophisticated about the way they
approach women
so if you went to the bar you couldn't
ask one girl out and then go ask another
girl out and then go back to the first
and say all right
you had to pick the one you wanted
and that was the only one selection yeah
you have to scan the room for a good 10
minutes to see which one you want to
talk to because
you didn't want to go for the wrong one
all right
well I I think more men would approach
women in public and like maybe social
skills would improve yeah because you
don't have that option and to avoid
rejection I think women too yeah like I
said before you see everyone would go
out more yeah yeah before I had laser
eye surgery I was technically ugly to
like 99 of women right
remove my glasses grew my hair all of a
sudden I'm attractive and I'm six foot
plus so it doesn't matter if I've got a
mattress on the floor you're still
coming over me
after the fact and even then I'm cooking
you breakfast in the morning so she
you're coming back for round two because
you like breakfast in the morning forget
the mattress on the floor yeah they love
me but you don't have to be the
six-figure guys to get to get to run the
crutches
you get crutches if if you apply
yourself yeah I just think if those like
I feel like a lot of problems would be
solved if literally we got rid of birth
control on social media wow yeah because
because women would have to be more
selective with who they sleep with yeah
I mean
like maybe I know you said pull out but
like since they actually have
what do you think is the biggest
challenge for women when it comes to
social media and what they see on a
daily basis
um I think it inflates like women's ego
so like I think a lot of times we think
we're hotter than we are right that yeah
so that's your point pal I feel like
there's a date in inflation going on at
the minute yeah in a sense of where
you've got all these like fives and
sixes who used to be able to get out of
push seven or eight who are now gonna
[__] them seven and eight we want tens
out of tens do you know what I'm saying
I think women's social media has
heightened women's ex social media has
heightened women's expectations of what
it is that they desire in a man it's
just like took it through the roof and
it's like they expect you know 25 out of
10 type of man every single time so it
gives men this like perception that the
average girl is actually super super hot
because if you look at how many
relationships are struggling because the
guy likes random girls pictures on the
internet and also how many women are
comparing themselves to other women on
Instagram what do you think about that
I'm curious
of which part A man liking a woman's
pictures on Instagram it's contextual
based on what the picture is who the
woman is like if it's a friend that he
met before me who happens to be female
who happens to be a girl totally fine if
it's a badly on the on the on the scroll
page whatever you call it that he's
never seen before from America yeah I
don't I don't think that's okay but I
also think that a guy who's got sexual
discipline wouldn't want to do that in
the first place like my boyfriend
doesn't follow any bikini models on
Instagram it's not because I told him to
unfollow them he just doesn't yeah and
that speaks a lot to the that speaks a
lot to the values that you play in that
relationship as well that'd be a waste
of time anyway there's no point liking
all these people on social media which
is gorgeous because it just inflates
them as well fifteen hundred thousand
people like me in this bikini yeah
I saw her on Tinder and one girl I knew
she was only fans because I looked on
her Instagram and then I went on it and
then she said follow me on Instagram
like I'm not going on your only fans
yeah I'm meeting people in real life and
then on her Instagram was hi hi I met
you on Tinder I met you on Tinder and
not gonna ever she's probably got an
assistant to try to sell you on her own
event I'm good yeah I'm not I'm not
paying if if I if I was saying good and
I see a girl with like thousands of
likes it's like a it's like a impulse
not to not not to join the crowd because
I don't want to be part of a crowd I
want to be part of 15 000 people what's
that about do you know what's funny
right I know I've got a couple of
friends who I've known from back in
school who have now obviously become
they were attractive at school era and
now they've become like these insta no
no Instagram models but they're they use
their attractiveness to make money right
and when I when I when I see them I'll
see their post and I'm like well you got
10 000 likes
boys
because again you know my mattress on
the floor and that so
um but at the same time they'll hit me
back and be like yo what are you saying
you're good you bless you and I'm like
yeah but I think it's all materialistic
you know what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying if social media went away like We
need to bring back meeting people in
person and having conversations in
person and speaking on the phone
you know it's something I did when I got
to London because here it's like less
friendly I think and so I had this idea
I was like I'm gonna just say hi to
people walking down the street and like
see how many say hi back and I've never
gotten so many crazy looks like I was
like hi and then they were just looking
like I'm nuts but I'm from Chicago and
I'm from the suburbs you could just do
that but yeah here I guess it's like
they grab something of them wallet or
they're personal
yeah yeah I think I had one or two
it's like a different I know people in
London think Chicago's like crazy and it
is but I'm not I'm not from like the
yeah
you came from Chicago which is has its
reputation as a whole yeah you came to
London thinking that people are gonna
say hi to you yes I was hoping
she's like me guys
okay well I think I'm gonna close out
the show so um why don't we go around
any final thoughts funny super chats you
want to speak your piece on you know go
ahead
I'll start off off the bat I'm not a
beta all right Blackberry tea Blackberry
Productions presents the chop
like And subscribe and you'll see one as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible